la tensión en la Península de Corea ha
reaparecido el sábado un sorpresivo
lanzamiento de un misil holístico
intercontinental norcoreano tuvo lugar
Un día después de advertir sobre una
respuesta fuerte y sin precedentes por
los ejercicios militares que Corea del
Sur y Estados Unidos harán en las
próximas semanas
el simulacro sorpresa de lanzamiento del
misil balístico intercontinental es una
prueba real de los esfuerzos constantes
de la fuerza nuclear estratégica de la
República popular democrática de Corea
para convertir su capacidad de
contraataque nuclear fatal contra las
fuerzas hostiles en una Irresistible
la televisión Estatal japonesa difundió
imágenes donde supuestamente el misil
vuela a la zona de hokkaido esta
operación encendió las alarmas de seúl y
Washington Quienes no demoraron en
ejecutar una respuesta conjunta e
inesperada el Estado Mayor conjunto
surcoreano emitió un comunicado al
respecto
en esta ocasión las maniobras han
demostrado la preparación y las
capacidades de defensa combinadas de
Corea del Sur y Estados Unidos al
exhibir la abrumadora fuerza de la
alianza mediante el oportuno e inmediato
despliegue de los activos de disuasión
de Estados Unidos en la Península
coreana también confirmó el compromiso
inquebrantable de Estados Unidos y los
compromisos de disuasión ampliada
Washington Se comprometió con seúl a
realizar una disuasión contra la
actividad militar norcoreana quienes
hicieron frecuentes pruebas de armas
pero lejos de Cesar las hostilidades las
pujas continúan